نقلت وسائل اعلام امريكيه عن المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه ادم هودج ان
الولايات المتحده تراقب تطورات الوضع في
روسيا
وستتشاور مع الحلفاء والشركاء بخصوصها
واضافها تم اطلاع الرئيس جو بايدن على تلك
التطورات وافادت ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
يتوخون الحذر بشان اصدار اي تصريحات حول
ما يحدث في روسيا بسبب تسارع الاحداث اذا
هذا فيما يخص رد الفعل الامريكي وحول ذلك
انضم الينا من فيرجينيا مراسل الجزيره
ناصر الحسيني اذا كيف تراقب الولايات
المتحده ما يجري في روسيا
نعم هناك الان في هذه الاثناء الصمت
الشديد على جميع مستويات خارجيه تنتجون او
بيت ابيض ما يتم الحديث عنه الان هو في
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه انطلاقا من مصادر
مطلعه حال وقريبه جدا من الاداره بشكل انه
باخر مياده ما حصل اليوم في اوكرانيا وهذه
الازمه مع مجموعه
لحد ما وحتى اكثرهم تحليلا ومراقبه في
اوكرانيا لا اظن انه حتى اللحظه كان يتوقع
ان مجموعه فاجنر المقاتله في اوكرانيا يصل
بها الامر الى ان تهدد بشكل او باخر
عسكريا القوات التي تعمل من اجلها
وبالتالي لنقل صراحه رغم ان البيت الابيض
لم يتحدث بعد الخارجيه
او اي محلل رسمي امريكي لنقل ان هذه اخبار
ساره صحيح مزعجه كما يقول زميلي في موسكو
زاور لكن اخبار مفرحه هي دائما ما كان
يتحدث عنها ربما المتحللون الامن المحللون
الامريكيون لطالما كرر المحلل الامريكيون
دون ان نصدق ذلك بالفعل ان الرئيس بوتين
ضعيف والجبهه العسكريه ضعيفه والبنيه
البنيه العسكريه الاستراتيجيه الامنيه
ضعيفه ربما يرى الامريكيون فيما يحدث الان
من هذه التصريحات وهذه التجاوزات انصحها
للتعبير
يرون فيها صدعا في البنيه الروسيه في هذه
الحرب التي يبدو انها لن تتوقف قريبا كثير
من المحلين الامريكيين سيستبقون الاداره
الامريكيه ليعتبروا ما يحدث نوعا من
الانقلاب على سياسات سياسات العسكريه
لبوتينر مثالا ونموذجا بدات بشكل او باخر
ترفض هذه التعليمات العسكريه وطريقه الحرب
وطريقه اجرائها هذه انباء ساره
ايضا لمجموعه نيتو قبل قليل تحدث بشكل
مقتضب مستشار الامن القومي
الا انت انصاره ربما تؤكد الى حد ما
تنبؤات كثير من الاستراتيجيه الامريكيين
بان تلك الاله العسكريه الضخمه الروسيه
ليست بالقوه
العسكريه والتنظيم المطلوب من دوله عصريه
نوويه وبالتالي واشنطن صامته لانها تريد
ان تفهم ما يحدث بعدها سيكون لكل حادث
حديث بطبيعه الحال لكن الامريكيين وباخر
يمكن تاكيد ذلك حتى قبل المسؤولين رسميا
هذه انباء جد سرام مياده من الساحه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وجد مشجعه
والرئيس بايدن الى اخره وبالتالي الكل
مسرور الالي ما يحدث هناك على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والروسيه اذا الولايات المتحده
مسروره ولكن هل كانت تتوقع حدوث هذا
الخلاف بهذا الشكل بين فاجنر ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وبين موسكو عموما خاصه
انها لطالما كانت تنتقد استخدام رو
سيا لشركه فاجنر
التوقعات الامريكيه منذ البدايه كانت
دائما تعتبر ان روسيا ليست لا تمثل بالفعل
قوه ليس عسكريه لانما قوه قادره على
الاستمرار في الحرب الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
الحسابات الامريكيه وحسابات منذ البدايه
كانت اسلوب الاستنزاف ما يحدث الان هديه
من السماء للامريكيين والنيتو لم يكن احد
يتوقع ان المشكله ستكون في كانت التوقعات
التحليلات نظريه المؤامره ان احدا ما من
المقربين من
قصر الكريم ربما يتجرا ربما يحاول
الانتقاد ربما يحاول الخروج عن سلطه بوتين
وبالتالي اضعافه سياسيا داخل لكن لم نرى
في التنبؤات الامريكيه للخبراء
والاستراتيجيه وحتى على مستوى رسمي تنبؤات
بان مجموعه فاغنمر يوما ما قد تتحول الى
عدو عسكري داخلي هذا تطور جد مفاجئ سياسي
عسكريا والان الغرب امريكا على راسهم تقف
وتراقب تحاول ان تفهم لكن بدون شك
الولايات المتحده الان جدو مرتاحه في
موقفها وهذا دليل اخر الان سيسوقه الرئيس
داخليا بان هذه الحرب على وش كنت وانا كما
قرر الامريكيون دائما رجل او زعيم سياسي
ضعيف وارته العسكريه مهلهله غير منظمه
والدليل فيما يحدث الان مع مجموعه التي هي
الشركه خاصه في نهايه لكن يبرز الامريكيين
الى حد ما هناك هذا التخبط في التخطيط
الاستراتيجي في الاداء على الارض الى اخره
الباء صار في كل الحالات